[Musique]
e
bonsoir à tous et à tout bon soir laury
dance à la montée des marches
exceptionnelle aujourd'hui sur canal+
70e festival de cannes une journée un
peu particulière bien évidemment que
vous en doutez le festival de cannes a
tenu à rendre hommage à tous les morts
je te dramatique attentat qui a eu lieu
la nuit dernière à manchester et c'est
vrai que c'était une journée très
particulière alors évidemment on va
continuer à vous faire vivre tout ça
depuis les marches mais tout le tout le
monde ici s'associe bien sûr au drame
qui a eu lieu hier
alors énormément de personnalités ce
soir pour le 70e anniversaire monica
bellucci qu'étant de 5,7 mois voilà lors
il est avec moi donc exceptionnellement
pour les marches ce soir
jouve et monica bellucci
monica bellucci maîtresse de cérémonie
de ce 62e festival de cannes qui sera
dimanche soir sur canal + pour présenter
la cérémonie de clôture exercice qu'elle
fait pour la seconde fois
elle est enfin de répondre aux questions
de dj but
alain taton
non
merci cher leader
aussi également l'arrivée de charlize
theron ou mat hörmann qui était là il ya
quelques instants également
et eva longoria qu était présent à
cannes pour le global gift gala puisque
c'est son gala de charité également pour
l'oréal on l'a rencontré il ya quelques
instants regarder les images
aulas yeux bandés les roues magnifique
qu'est ce qui représente s'amuse
beaucoup penser au présent et lisa
tuttle et à bhl célèbre ses réalisateurs
et bien sûr tous ces failles sur gmail
aux sommes qui doivent faire tout le
monde ils n'auraient pas l'universalité
steve acheter quelque chose
merci beaucoup
en bas des marches des noix de cajou
gillet cette année pour présenter en
compétition le film de michael haneke
happy end mais y'a forcément plein de
souvenirs qui reviennent ce soir en tête
bah oui j'ai fait je pense des deux
films à cannes en tant que réalisateur
et c'est toujours un moment extrêmement
fort donc ces gens là on va venir ici
pour une réponse pour présenter ton
meilleur souvenir c'est resta
présentation de la haine envers ce gir
ça reste représentation d' assassin qui
a été froidement accueillie ouais mais
c'était fait pour donc chassé fier du
résultat mais aussi bonne soirée
matyassy avons monica soixante dix ans
ce sera pour le festival de cannes que
vous avez tous vécu à cannes des
émotions fortes et émettrait de
cérémonie cherisay présenter des films
dans quel état d'esprit vous sentez ce
soir mais ce soir c'est magnifique
il ya plein de l'acteur et du qatar
n'est pas du temps qui ont fait
l'histoire de cannes et tout le monde
est là pour remercier kahn parce que je
crois que pour tous ces gens qui sont là
ce soir ça ça va me donner beaucoup et
tous les plus beaux films sont passés
par là et alors que moi je pense que
cannes représente la forme culturelle de
la france et du monde entier
c'est c'était terrenoire d'être là ce
soir dimanche vous présenter la
cérémonie de clôture du festival quand
est ce que vous pouvez déjà nous dire à
quoi s'attendre pour cette cérémonie
mais encore on peut rien dire ça
s'arrête là surprise
mais le mois il ya des choses que je
sais mais des choses qui vont sûrement
arrivé dernier moment et c'est ça la
beauté du spectacle on sera là dimanche
merci monica
charlize charlize charlie chaplin
charlize j'essayais de faire charlize
theron mais c'est pas gagné
charlize theron que vous voyez sur ces
images il s'apprête à faire là la montée
des marches
charlize theron donc il va alors qu'un
instant donc être sur le tapis rouge
voilà à l'occasion on vous le disait du
70è donc anniversaire du festival de
cannes
[Musique]
il ya quelques instants toujours en bas
des marches et michael haneke qui
étaient avec nous il fait partie du club
pierre privilégié des metteurs en scène
avoir obtenu ici deux palmes d'or
c'était pour amour et le ruban blanc
michael haneke on écoute avec nous là
quelques instants c'est beaucoup
d'émotion pour vous ce soir ce 70e
anniversaire
je t'ai déjà au soixantième anniversaire
c'est bien oui pas de beaucoup d'émotion
vous faites partie du club très fermé
des réalisateurs qui ont eu deux pas le
mode hors jeu pour moi rien j'ai
tellement fort
je suis sourd excusez vous pas de
problème voilà pour vous dire qu'il ya
beaucoup de bruit à beaucoup de monde et
c'est vrai qu'on n'entend pas toujours
valeria golino qui est à côté de moi on
va dire un petit mot valérien valeria
qui est en train de danser
valeria qui dansait à l'instant valeria
golino valeria qui était en train de
danser bonsoir les reds étaient en train
de danser c'est la fait plaisir parce
que j'ai vraiment c'est la belle étoile
à celles à faible risque et c'est
vraiment que la fête s'est pas
l'attention c'est pas la perd le fil
c'est là la famille alors absents merci
voilà valeria golino avec nous on va les
marches
[Musique]
oui
et gael garcia bernal qui est avec moi
je rappelle que vous avez monté les
marches plusieurs fois notamment pour
babel alejandro gonzalez inarritu
tu te présente pour vous ce festival à
wayne parmi les îles espagnoles ces
[Musique]
princesses c'est pas de bis et je suis
ravi d'être ici que je retrouve
d'ailleurs une autre la mort d'autres
nous sommes tous très heureux
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
voilà en bas des marches donc en bas des
marches avec toute ces tous ceux qui ont
fait les festivals de cannes depuis des
années et qui sont en train d'arriver
acteurs actrices réalisateurs
producteurs qu'au moment où je vous
parle je vois al gore l'ex vice
président des états unis qui est lui
présenté cette année un documentaire et
puisque juste derrière lui pardon a dès
lors qu on coule on sait exactement
combien nous nous rejoindre alors en les
attendant parce qu'il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de monde je vous propose de
découper carole bouquet elle était avec
nous il ya quelques instants carole
bouquet bonsoir carole et le plaisir de
vous voir
70e festival de cannes c'était un pur
bout important d'être là ce soir très
important c'est toujours important
d'être là au festival de cannes
et c'est vrai que ça fait longtemps que
je me souviens pas de visage en disant
quand même moi je vous le confirme avec
que des bons souvenirs forcément les
vents solaires des souvenirs fou
délirant mais exagéré mais merveilleux
mais si on doit en retenir un ce serait
lequel
je prends de jeu créneau est le premier
en fait le vide werner schroeter le jour
des idiots
j'étais en compétition pour l'allemagne
on se faisait nul et et ont même temps
mais y avait mes jambes
le james bond dont cape town que je
traversais donc deux univers vraiment
c'est tellement différent et on en
profite hommage à roger moore qui est
décédé aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup car en début d'année
salma hayek françois pinault qui sont en
train d'arriver nous sommes en direct
on va les accueillir on va juste revoir
un petit mot de maïwenn qui étaient avec
nous il ya quelques instants ont regardé
un mot sur ce festival que vous
connaissez bien sur lesquels vous avez
vécu beaucoup d'émotions
c'est assez magique de revenir
génial tous ces réalisateurs et de
pouvoir parler de cinéma voilà vous avez
une belle séance photo ce midi tous
ensemble je pense qu'il y avait beaucoup
d'émotion qu'est-ce que vous êtes dit
les uns les autres au nom n'est pas
beaucoup d'émotion et beaucoup
d'hystérie surtout ouais on était tous
groupe idéal les autres ce serait
marrant
qu'est ce que vous avez envie de
souhaiter au festival de cannes pour la
suite de la continuer à prendre des
risques de découvrir des réalisateurs
audacieux ne jamais aller dans la
facilité de de continuer à partout
pourquoi
merci beaucoup voilà toujours en bas des
marches vous voyait peut-être sur ces
images alejandro gonzalez innaritu cayla
qui s'apprête à monter tapis rouge gael
garcia bernal
benicio del toro voilà c'est toute la
communauté mexicaine qui est là ça va
bien ça va
voilà et salma hayek qui juste derrière
on va essayer d'avoir un petit mot avec
salma hayek qui est juste derrière nous
je vois également edouard baer karin
viard emmanuelle devos
voilà ils sont tous là dans un instant
ça va être cette montée des marches
qu'on vous disait exceptionnel on va
essayer d'avoir un petit mot avec salma
hayek qui va venir nous rejoindre dans
quelques secondes
vous voyez sur ces images
[Musique]
salma hayek combat et essayé
d'intercepter dans dans quelques minutes
elle en attendant en attendant je vous
propose
histoire de patienter un mois que
j'attends qu'ils me dernière je la tente
une dernière
salma salma ya salama tonemassa basics
acting besoin de trouver des fonds pour
vous d'être ici je vous entends pas
malheureusement c'est exciting tous ses
fidèles importants ont dit que ce soit
vraiment au fait j'ai pleuré après un
film je n'arrivais pas à croire ce que
j'étais en fait pas du tout mes héros
toutes les personnes que j'admire
tellement donc c'est vraiment un honneur
si beaucoup seulement voilà salma seul
mario world et karin viard également
qu'on voit sur ces images
edouard baer sandrine kiberlain emmanuel
de gosses 10 points
tous vont venir nous rejoindre enfin en
tout cas on l'espère beaucoup de bruit
beaucoup de monde vous le voyez
d'ailleurs vous l'entendez c'est vrai
qu'il y en a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de mal à se parler en bas des marches
vous en rendez peut-être pas compte chez
vous mais c'est extrêmement compliqué de
faire des interviews ici
[Musique]
voilà avant de retrouver dans un instant
sandrine kiberlain emmanuel gauche vous
propose d'écouter diane kruger bien
compliqué à traiter avec nous il ya
quelques minutes
ken kruger c'est important pour vous ce
soir d'être ici à cannes célébrer le 70e
anniversaire
pour moi tout a commencé à cali j'ai
reçu deux prix de chopard toute jeune
actrice et puis j'ai plein crime en
compétition qui ont eu ma carrière et je
reviens cette année en compétition avec
le gym pâte et akin donc tu es tu là en
plus était jury pour le 65e anniversaire
donc ce que je peux vous demander un
meilleur souvenir c'est la petite songes
des marges pour choyer noël qui a fait
quitter hors compétition mais que les
gens ont adoré il ya un ave maria chuté
en chant pendant qu'on descendait les
marchés les gens ici en larmes
ému donc c'était magnifique merci bonne
projection bonne soirée voilà regarder
ces contraintes de passer oui davies
james hughes à will smith qui m'a salué
le public membre du jury cette année à
cannes will smith qui prend le temps de
faire des elfi de signer des autographes
will smith en bas des marches will smith
qui est la caisse créée très en retard
puisque on est en train de prendre
beaucoup de retard sur sur la cérémonie
on va essayer de faire une petite
question avec avec will voulait smith
qui vous voyez sur ces images donc est
en train de s'embrasser de faire des
selles fi des autographes
we are you doing to night oui ça va ce
soir je m'amuse comme un fou
voilà will ils sont très en retard donc
on nous demande d'abréger no no
interview
[Musique]
énormément de monde ce soir évidemment
on célébrer le 70e anniversaire du
festival de cannes
karin viard edouard baer 70e
anniversaire du festival de cannes deux
habitués dans quel état d'esprit vous
svp une photo de celui du tous ensemble
ça s'est passé comment écouter je trouve
que j'étais tout à fait fraternelle
assez peu de baston hp2m pas de coup
fourré pas de pic q vous savez les fidji
comme nom moi là bas car il ya eu des
grands d'une beauté elle a été
international elle a tellement de
barrières étaient bien présents pour
vous sauver
c'est le cinéma cinéma dans ses doigts
et extrêmement bien dit merci à tous les
deux voilà de retour avec jessica
chastain will smith était en train de
signer des autographes on retrouve
jessica qui également on va faire des
photos est en train de de signer
quelques autographes
jessica chastain que vous découvrez donc
sur ces images en bas des marches 70e
anniversaire de cannes
ah oui au fils thomas que je sais
comment vous sentez ce soir je suis très
heureux c'est chasser mais ici pour des
72e anniversaire voilà jessica chastain
membres membres du jury là encore on est
très très en retard donc on nous demande
de faire court mais vous avez cette
image de jessica chastain en bas des
marches toujours alors que une fois
encore énormément d'invités continuent
d'arriver
arrivé de ma peau nickel sont agnès
jaoui un coin j'en profite
hayek on peut évidemment pas par les as
de la sélection mais comment est ce que
vous vivez c'est un plaisir c'est
surtout dû être très intéressant de voir
des films de cette qualité à la suite et
puis d'en discuter avec des gens de
cette qualité merci beaucoup grandes
forêts et excusez moi mais j'ai une
pensée pour manchester sait que c'est un
peu compliqué mais je suis quand même
obligé d'en parler parce que c'est un
peu étrange s'avérer temps d'en parler
[Musique]
voilà alors regardez will smith qui est
en train de revenir
will smith qui revient qui va faire le
tapis rouge vous le voyez peut-être sur
ces images très très en forme et loïc
regardez c'est très compliqué en fait tu
peux vous dire c'est qu'il ya énormément
dreux ya énormément de retard officiel
forcément avec tous les événements la
sécurité est extrêmement remporté ce
soir sur la croisette
le voilà maintenant il faut qu'ils
aillent habiter à la corée du 110e
anniversaire
je leur avais team dc oui je suis avec
benicio benicio et et vincent lindon
j'essaie de voir un petit mot vincent
léchenne avoir un petit mot quand
vincent vincent masson et madame
entendre maintenant il ya beaucoup de
bruit
bon alors d'un sans qui il ne souhaite
pas s'exprimer mais tu m'embrasses et
embrasse fort matt mickelson qui est là
également
new dance matt you want to dance your
world dance night je viens à cannes j'ai
envie qsi thonaille commenter non ça va
ce serait super 70 ans croyait beaucoup
de culture tout cas pas de l'amour et la
beauté maison qu'on trouve nulle part
ailleurs sur le match mais voilà bat
nicholson
avec neuf éditions
bonjour démission je suis là le mental
et vous très bien aux messieurs de
douter combien de photos privées
trente deux 32 la vie de l'acteur will
you lie de sa cause perdue est ce que
vous aimez cette atmosphère est ce que
ce serait jeter dehors j'adore
moi j'ai grandi avec le festival de
cannes c'est ma maison pour ainsi dire
mais oui je le rappelle que lui
souhaiter bon anniversaire lieu à
diverses
merci voilà toujours en bas des marches
ya énormément de bruit et de monde c'est
pour ça que de temps en temps on est
obligé de répéter avec le riz 2 à 3 fois
nos questions parce qu'il ya un
vainqueur mais infernal ici on attend
encore du monde bien évidemment vincent
lindon
benicio qui était avec lorient un
instant max nicholson se sont tous les
prix d'interprétation masculine
ici à cannes qui vont donc dans un
instant monter les marches
je crois qu'il ya ce soir laurence plus
de 120 personnalités qui monte lema
exactement en même temps certaines
paroles et prix d'interprétation
masculine féminine l'animal devant aussi
si tu es tu arrivé dans cette salle il
ya beaucoup de monde j'ai beaucoup de
malentendus petit il va oui c'est bien
c'est un jury andré dussollier avec la
partie 1-1 sans les food andré
dussollier j'entends rien andré vous
oubliez vos droits et vous commentez et
bien bien écoutez vincent on peut mieux
quoi c'est magnifique remontée des
marges bien le bonjour d'agréable et
rouffach de gamme de rencontrer des gens
qui vous aiment tout au long de la
croisette site la journée si c'est bien
tu rencontré déjà entre soi en tracteur
venir en scène qu'on n'a pas l'habitude
de voir d'un coup comme ça d'un seul
devant les champs le public en effet de
participer un anniversaire après avoir
vécu pas mal de festivals
voilà il ya tout ça qui réunit en un
seul instant qu'eric chose d'assez
extraordinaire mais marion cotillard en
direct avec nous sur canal+
marion l'une des rares d'actrice à entre
80 et aux 108 ces dernières années à
caricature présent procédure en cours
des plus beaux ses principales de ces
mamans
j'ai toujours très honoré de piètres
avec avec des films que j'aime et je
pense faire bizarre l'année où je vais
pas venir parce que c'est vrai ça fait
sept ans maintenant six ans que je viens
les sept ans que j'ai des films en
sélection et je me sens très très
chanceux c'est vrai mais nous on veut
pouvoir chaque année je vais chaque
année oui voila je viendrai là oui sinon
je vous aime
justement qu'est ce qu'on peut souhaiter
au festival de cannes pour la suisse bat
qui est toujours autant de diversité qui
que ce soit un festival libre et qu'il
continue à faire découvrir des des
cinéastes des acteurs d d d idées d
du monde entier voilà des cultures c'est
simon ça qu'il est si vivante et
décision voilà marion cotillard à
l'instant qui était avec laurie cholewa
c'est vrai que depuis sept ans les biens
tous les ans festival de cannes
beaucoup beaucoup de monde ce soir tout
ça je n'en savais pas ce que tu entends
pas grand chose et moi on en profite
voilà exactement c'est la fête ce soir à
cannes je vois christophe walt balles ce
qui arrive on va essayer de voir un
petit mot avec lui et on va essayer
d'avoir un petit mot alors est ce qu'on
attend de faire un petit mot avec avec
christophe laurier cei et le temps
favori baby just one je vois l'histoire
du cinéma se dérouler sous nos cieux
je vois des plus grands réalisateurs et
zemmour lahbib édition des tauromaches
c'est sa canne
[Musique]
voilà toujours en bas des marches ya
toujours beaucoup de monde beaucoup de
bruit il ya quelques instants lambert
wilson le petit coquin était tout seul
dans son coin en train de en train de
signer des autographes lambert avec nous
il ya quelques minutes on écoute on vous
attendait d'autres côté lambert mais je
sais pas où je suis lâche un peu j'ai
l'impression ni là je l'aï vu il ya
tellement de monde alors voilà je vais
aller me balader un peu c'est marrant
c'est pas un alléchant ils sont qu'à
tellement sympathique c'est incroyable
ils sont en plein soleil
ils attendent des heures et des heures
donc merci pour eux mêmes et pas ce
qu'est ce qu'ils vont voir passer quand
même c'est ce qu'on a vécu nous ce matin
en photos extraordinaires la nommer la
réunion des gens qui sont là ce soir
les metteurs en scène les acteurs ce
matin dans la séance de photos c'était à
ce qu'il fallait se passer quoi on se
tourne il ya cannes l'autre chance
tourne ya niaré tout et ensuite j'ai pas
nicole kidman et kirsten dunst se passer
c'est juste un truc et robert wilson
non mais on est moi j'ai fait des photos
quoi comme un fan quoi mais on est fan
merci moi c'est être c'est du sport je
n'avais pas vu c'est du sport non
l'aller mais je m'étais bien entraîné
mais je m'attendais pas à autant de tort
vous allez encore beaucoup de monde qui
doit venir mais nous dans un instant on
va marquer une petite pause et puis on
vous retrouvera plus qu'à le moment je
laisse faire
en plateau bien sûr avec eux avec lorie
et on commentera vous inquiétez pas les
marches pour va continuer d'enregistrer
parce que ils sont très en retard et on
attend encore énormément de monde sharon
stone doit venir nicole kidman je crois
en elle mais gore aussi osé palme d'or
et loire de cannes
voilà donc on va on va encore rester un
tout ce qui peut à des cours d'idées
plutôt alors reconnu impersonnalité
remonter les marches ce soir
et justement et les fanning qui est là
pour représenter le film les proies de
sofia coppola était avec nous il ya
quelques instants regarder
au uk on est épuisé mais puisent avec
mes missions accomplies c'était vraiment
la fête
évidemment énormément de bruit
énormément de monde on va se retrouver
juste après la pub on sera en plateau
quel moment et fleurie et ont comme en
train continuera de commenter les matchs
a tout de suite je bougeais pas tout
bouge pas non responsable en direct
surtout sur canal+ a tout de suite
[Musique]